Guten Abend, Berkis, mein Name, ich bin zuständig für Sie, bevor wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden kommen, benötige ich einige persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Hallo, guten Abend, hallo. Mein Name ist Franz Walter.
Franz Walter. Herr Walter, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 48 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 15. Juni 1978.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie so seit?
Herr Doktor, warum diese ganzen Fragen? Ich habe Schmerzen und Sie fragen mich nach meiner Größe. Das verstehe ich nicht.
Können wir nicht immer kommen, Herr Doktor?
Was für Schmerzen haben Sie im Moment?
Seit zwei Stunden hier auf der rechten Seite, das ist so richtig kolikartig, ich kann die Schmerzen nicht mehr aushalten, das wird immer schlimmer.
Seit zwei Stunden haben Sie Schmerzen im Rückenbereich?
Nein, nein, nein. Hier vorne am Bauch.
Hier von der oberen Seite und strahlt nach unten im Bereich der Handblase.
Waren Sie plötzlich oder langsam?
Vor zwei Stunden, das hat erst mal ganz langsam angefangen.
Dann ist es immer schlimmer geworden. Ich kann es kaum aushalten, das ist vollkommen schmarr.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Ein Schmerzfall von 1 bis 10, 1 Stadt für sehr leichte Schmerzen, 10 Stadt für unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Das ist bei 7,8 würde ich sagen, das ist ganz heftig geworden.
Ja, ich kann Sie gut verstehen. Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzen-Mittel geben?
Bitte, das wäre ganz toll, danach können wir weiter reden von mir aus.
Ich habe schon EBO-Profen geschmückt, aber das hat mir überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Okay, bitte lege Sie auf der Lege, ich lege eine Naden und über die eine Medikamente geben.
Aber vorsichtig, ich habe eine Novalginalägie, bitte.
Entschuldigung, bevor wir eine Medikamente geben, Nevalginalägie.
Ja, bitte keine Novalgien.
Okay, meistens bekomme ich dann immer Paracetamol als Infusion, das hilft immer ganz gut.
Okay, ich gebe Paracetamol oder Sramadol.
Egal, die Schmerzen sind weg, Herr Doktor.
Okay, können wir ja weiter machen?
Vielen Dank, das ist schon mal gut. Ich glaube, die Schmerzen werden schon etwas besser.
Ja, gerne, bitte schön.
Herr Walter, wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben, sind sie dummstehend, kollegartig, brennend?
Nee, das ist so kollegartig, so richtige Wellen, das macht auf und zu.
Und ich dachte zuerst, wahrscheinlich fühlt sich eine Geburt so an, das ist so heftig.
Das kommt und geht, das kommt vom rechts oben und strahlt bis in das Bein oder bis in die Handblase, so in den Unterbauch.
Und das wird immer schlimmer.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, und ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich muss auf Toilette, ich gehe auf Toilette, aber da kommt wenig Wasser rein.
Neben diese Schmerzen haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel haben Sie Überweilheit.
Ja, wenn Sie das so sehen, sagen, eine Übelkeit habe ich schon, erbrechen habe ich bisher noch nicht, aber so eine Übelkeit ist dabei.
Okay, hatte Sie einen Unfall vielleicht, Herr Walter?
Nein, Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay, solche Schmerzen haben Sie früher gehabt?
Ich hatte mal vor 3, 3 Jahren mal so ähnliche Schmerzen, aber so schlimm wie jetzt war das nicht.
Würden Sie sagen, dass diese Schmerzen von etwas abhängig sind, zum Beispiel Nahrungsabhängig, Bewegungsabhängig?
Nein, das kommt ohne Ende ein Grund.
Haben Sie nur so eine Brustschmerz oder Engelgefilm in der Brust?
Auf der Brust? Nein, da habe ich kein Problem.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie zu Hause etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe Überprofilen genommen, ich hatte Überprofilen 600 Milligramm zu Hause.
Das habe ich mir sofort eingeworfen.
Hab das geholfen? Nein, bis Sie überhaupt können.
Deswegen bin ich da.
Sie haben gut gemacht, Herr Walter.
Haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie häufig Wasser lassen haben?
Ich habe so einen Andrang, wo ich das Gefühl habe, ich muss auf Toilette, aber es kommt kein Urin.
Wie sieht Ihr Urin aus? Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches Farbveränderung bei mir?
Nein, das war jetzt nichts Auffälliges. Wie immer gleich.
Okay, haben Sie vielleicht Blut im Urin bei mir?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Bisher war alles in Ordnung, nein.
Haben Sie neben dieser Schmerz viel Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieberig, Herr Walter?
Nein, ich war bis vor zwei, drei Stunden noch völlig gesund.
Ich habe keinen Stuhlfrost.
Nein, kein Schüttelfrost.
Ich nehme auch keine Medikamente, ich habe bis jetzt nichts.
Wie sieht Ihr Apetit aus? Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Apetitveränderung bei mir?
In letzter Zeit, nein.
Alles in Ordnung, ich kann sehr gut essen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Gewicht auf oder so?
Nein, das habe ich jetzt nichts bei mir, ist alles gleich.
Können Sie gut schlafen in letzter Zeit?
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme damit?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme damit.
Herr Walter, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Brustschmerzen haben.
Vielleicht haben Sie Herzblubben bemerkt?
Nein, alles in Ordnung.
Ich habe nichts.
Haben Sie Atemprobleme, zum Beispiel Pusten?
Nein, ich habe keine Beschwerden, keine Luftnoten, keine Atemprobleme.
Ich mache regelmäßig Sport, ich bin zweimal die Woche beim Fußballbremling.
Also bisher war alles in Ordnung.
Das ist gut.
Herr Walter, ich möchte einige Fragen zu Ihrer Krankengeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie unter krönchen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit,
Lütochtlub, Erkrankungen, etc.
Ich bin nicht bekannt, ich werde jetzt auch seit 3 Jahren nicht Hausarzt,
aber ich habe bisher keine Beschwerden gehabt.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Ventilanteien?
Nein.
Wie gesagt, nur Schmerztabletten, wenn ich mal ein bisschen Beschwerden habe.
Okay, wurden Sie schon einmal okkuriert?
Ich glaube, als Kind habe ich, habe ich mir die Mandeln rausgenommen.
Haben Sie sonst weitere Operationen in der Vergangenheit?
Nein, glücklicherweise, bis heute habe ich alles noch drin.
Ja, gut.
Herr Walter, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine neue Allergie haben.
Haben Sie noch weitere Allergen oder Unverzweckheiten bekannt?
Gegen Medikamente habe ich jetzt keine Allergen, aber gegen Polen habe ich schon manchmal schlimme Symptome.
Da bekomme ich so ganz rote Augen und meine Nase läuft.
Ich kann nachts nicht nachhafen und da brauche ich auch immer so ein Cortisonspray.
Das hilft mir dann ganz gut.
Aber das ist ja immer früher.
Wie war die neue Allergen?
Ich hatte auch wieder mal so leichte Rückenschmerzen gehabt, zum Beispiel bei einem Freund.
Er hat mir diese gegeben und ich habe sofort darauf hin einen Ausschlag am ganzen Körper mit Juckreitz.
Dann mussten wir auch in die Notaufnahme und da haben die gesagt, das ist eine Novalginallergie und ich sollte das nicht nochmal nehmen.
Das ist gut.
Herr Walter, wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Sind Sie vorstellig geblieben?
Ich glaube, mein Hausarzt hat das letzte Mal gesagt, dass das alles in Ordnung ist.
Ich glaube, in zwei Jahren muss ich nochmal eine Auffrischung von der Täter machen.
Aber das war in Ordnung.
Okay, gut.
War sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
In letzter Zeit jetzt nicht, aber vor einem Jahr waren wir mal in Vietnam für zwei Wochen.
Aber ansonsten war es doch da, aber alles in Ordnung.
Es gab jetzt keine besonderen Auffälligkeiten.
Okay, gut.
Herr Walter, ich möchte noch etwas über Ihre Lebensgehung heute wissen.
Rauchen Sie?
Sehr selten.
Was meinen Sie sehr selten?
Wenn ich mal auf eine Feier bin oder auf ein Geburtstag, dann rauche ich vielleicht ansonsten nichts.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ich nehme es nicht, aber gelegentlich mal ein Wein oder manchmal ein Bier, aber auch nicht regelmäßig.
Okay.
Gutenweise muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Drogen haben.
Ja, was meinen Sie mit Drogen?
Also Kokain, Heroin nehme ich natürlich nicht.
Aber ab und zu mal so ein bisschen Gras rauchen, das mache ich schon mal.
Okay.
Ich möchte einige Erfragen, so wie Ihre Familiengeschichte, Herr Walter, sind bei Ihren Eltern chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Also soweit ich weiß, hat mein Vater einen hohen Blutdruck.
Er nimmt auch Medikamente ein.
Und ich glaube, er hat irgendein Problem mit der Prostata, soweit ich weiß, nimmt er auch Medikamente ein.
Aber sonst geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay, gut.
Ist bei Ihrer Mutter irgendwer, der Erkrankungen bekannt?
Also toll, toll, toll.
Meine Mutter geht es ganz gut.
Sie nimmt auch Medikamente gegen den Blutdruck soweit ich weiß.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist.
Ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt nichts, dass sie etwas hätte.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist drei Jahre jünger als ich und sie ist gesund, ja.
Okay, Herr Walter, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Zahntechniker.
Zahntechniker.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, ich habe immer mal wieder mal, mal mehr mal weniger, aber im Moment geht es eigentlich, ja.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstadt? Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe eine Tochter.
Ist die Tochter gesund?
Ja, ja, sie ist dreizehn Jahre alt, geht in diese Klasse, aber es geht ja ganz gut her.
Mhm, sehr gut.
Okay, Herr Walter, kurz zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ich möchte noch einige Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Handrank haben.
Ja.
Brennt es oder haben Sie Schmerzen dabei?
Also das Wasserlassen ist schon sehr schmerzhaft, stimmt.
Der ist jetzt auch so wellenartig und es brennt ein bisschen.
Mhm.
Ist also, ja, das tut weh, stimmt schon, ja.
Mhm, okay.
Herr Walter, ich habe keine Frage mehr.
Haben wir alles Beschwerden oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Erstmal vielen Dank, die Schmerzen sind ein bisschen besser geworden.
Aber ansonsten im Moment habe ich keine Fragen, danke.
Ich werde Sie jetzt noch Köpfe untersuchen.
Dann nehmen wir noch Bullute und eine Stuhlprobe
und dann machen einen Upperschall von Ihren Nieren
und Bauchberei.
Ich habe es angesprochen, ja, was das Problem sein könnte
oder die Befunde.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eher eine Nierenprobleme wie eine Nierensteine.
Oh, Sie denken an eine Nierenstein.
Ach ja, das fehlt mir noch.
Aber wir müssen mit der Untersuchung das bestätigen.
Okay, Herr Wunderbar, vielen Dank erst mal.
Bitte legen Sie auf der Lege.
Ich würde jetzt Köpfe untersuchen, wenn Sie verstanden sind.
Ja, danke. Bitte.
Danke schön, das war sehr schnell.
Können wir Fragen stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine ungeschützte Geschleßbärke?
Ich habe keine anderen Partner.
Ich bin jetzt nur mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Ich bin jetzt keine Kondom.
Die zweite Frage ist, trinken Sie genug Wasser am Tag?
Man kann natürlich immer mehr trinken, aber ich denke,
1,5 Liter am Tag, das schaffe ich noch.
Ich trinke Wasser.
Okay, gut. Danke.
Wir haben uns keine Fragen.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 m und wiege 95 kg.
Danke, Herr Kollege.
Hat da eine Enat richtig.
Super.
Sollen wir gleich weitermachen?
Wir brauchen noch ein paar Minuten für Arztgespräch.
Strahlen Sie sich an der Körperregion aus?
Bitte, war da noch eine Frage?
Wird der Ausstrahlung gefragt?
Ja, selbst gesagt.
Alle wurden schon gefragt.
Können wir anfangen?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberberg.
Gerade habe ich einen neuen Passiering gesehen,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Aber Herr Dr. Berg, natürlich. Hallo, guten Abend.
Schießen Sie mal los.
Was haben Sie genommen?
Es handelt sich um Herrn Franz Walter.
Er ist 48 Jahre alt, 1,80 m groß, 90 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns mit seit 2 Stunden bestehenden
zu nehmenden, wachseitige Flankenschmerzen,
die in den Rücken und Oberbauerbausch
ausstrahlen würden.
Unterbau.
Er beschrieb Schmerzen als kollegartig
und bewertete die Schmerzintensität mit 7 bis 8
auf eine Schmerzkala von 10.
Dabei habe ich einen Zugang gelegt
und ein Schmerzmittel gegeben.
Was haben Sie gegeben?
Traumatol.
Er hat eine Neuallergie,
das habe ich Traumatol gegeben.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut.
Er hat eine Neuallergie,
das hat er schon einmal gegeben,
aber nicht so schlimm.
Auf die Frage nach Brussschmerz,
Brussschmerz,
auf die Frage nach Brussschmerz,
Herzbechwerden, Antebechwerden wurden verneint.
Der Patient hat zu Hause Ibuprofen
600 Milligramm Eingeneum
und 10 Enennerswerte Linderung.
Okay.
Die Vegetar namenese ergab
diesuri,
polaxiuri,
polaxiuri und
ohne hematurie.
Okay.
Ansonsten war die Vegetar namenese unaufwendig.
Eine Vorerkrankung ist bei den Patienten bekannt.
Er nimmt nur bei Bedarf Schmerzmittel,
als Kind sei er eine Konstellaktomie durchgeführt worden.
Okay.
Eine Neuallgien,
Neuallgien und volle Neuergien sind bei ihm bekannt.
Die Neuallgienallergie
ist äußert sich mit Exantem und Prügetus.
Die Polenallergie,
die Polenallergie äußert sich mit
Renekoinaktivitis.
Okay.
Die Neuergienergie ist vollständig.
Reise an Amnesen war unaufwendig.
Sie treiben regelmäßig Sport.
Er treiben regelmäßig Sport.
Er raut sehr sehr den Zigaretten,
Trink, Gelegentlich Wein und Bier.
Er riecht ab und zu Gras.
Marihuana.
Okay.
In der Familie Annes ist zu erwähnen,
dass sein Vater eine arterielle Hypertonie
und Prostate Hyperpilasie,
wenn er eine Prostate Hyperpilasie hat,
hat eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Die Schwesterwein ist gesund.
Beruflich ist er als Santechniker tätig.
Sozial ist er verheiratet und hat eine gesunde Tochter.
Aufgrund der Diplomatik denke ich
auf eine Nephrolitiasis.
Okay.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen eine Cholilitiasis,
eine Appendicitis
und Urkus verendrückliche in Betrag.
Okay, ja, könnte passen.
Sie haben den Urinstatus gemacht.
Da ist eine Mikrohematurin drin,
ein bisschen Protein drin.
Im Ultraschall sehen Sie einen leichten Aufstau,
der in Ihrer Rechts.
Das wird auch diese Ergebnisse dazu passen.
Was könnte man noch machen,
wenn Sie einen Nierenstein
oder einen Hanleiterstein vermuten?
Welche Untersuchungen könnte man noch machen?
Ich werde eine CT veranlassen.
Genau, eine Computedomographie, genau.
Der Protein, wo der Stein ist, sehr gut.
Welche drei Engen gibt es denn im Hanleiter,
wo der Stein hängen bleiben kann?
Vielleicht nach dem Nieren
oder Ausgang der Nieren.
Und Kreuzbereich von Arterien.
Okay, schau mal.
drei Engen, das sollte man missen.
An welchen Steinen kann sein Nierenstein hängen bleiben?
Das müssen wir stellen, dass man da mal schaut.
Was ist die Therapie?
Was machen Sie jetzt mit dem?
Ich werde eine Schmerzmedikation verbrechen.
Als die ursachliche Therapie lege ich eine W-Hateta.
Ja, das würde man dann machen, wenn er...
Kann man machen, oder?
Nach dem SW...
Kommt noch, wenn der rein liegt.
Man muss nicht gleich eine Stoßwellentherapeutin machen,
aber erst mal Konservatil.
Schmerztabetten, Pilztrinker,
und Patienten laufen.
Spassmolitika, ja.
Spassmolitika.
Manchmal fallen die Steine von alleine auch ab.
Dann sind die Schmerzen auch mal spontan weg.
Das heißt, sie geben eben auch einen Filter,
damit er über diesen Filter sein Urin lässt.
Und dann sieht man manchmal, dass der Stein rauskommt.
Oder wenn alles nicht klappt,
dann können Sie ein Doppler-Kateta legen.
Und später dann nochmal mit einer Schlinge
Trans-Uretrat probieren, den Stein zu entfernen.
Sehr gut.
Wenn es nicht klappt, muss man operieren.
Ja.
Okay.
Das heißt, im Labor schauen Sie welche Werte nochmal genau an.
Die Werte sind wichtig jetzt bei Nierensteinen.
Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter wie CRT,
Nierenwerte, Kreativen, Handstoff.
Und, was noch?
Säure.
Handsohde auch hier.
Kalzium, Kalzium.
Kalzium und Phosphatwerte.
Das wäre auch wichtig genau.
Später Untersuchungen.
Sehr gut.
Wunderbar, das war sehr gut, Herr Doktor.
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen?
Oder sind alle damit einverstanden,
was Dr. Berke gemacht hat mit dem Patienten?
Keiner sagt etwas.
Alle haben sich Angst oder trauen sich nicht.
Ich kann noch mal vergessen.
Wann ist Ihre Prüfung?
27.11.
Das ist ja bald.
In Reutlingen, Baden-Württemberg.
Wo wohnen Sie denn?
In Ulm.
Ich habe studiert.